cette balade du morceau rock band est
particulièrement mélancolique pour terry
lynn port elle
pouvait bien jouer une
perte de motricité fine de mémoire
vertige et spasmes musculaires affecte
depuis deux ans la femme de 33 ans elle
fait partie des 48 patients de l'étude
sur un possible syndrome neurologique de
cause inconnue
il
laisse entendre la ministre de retirer
peuvent aussi hilarant et motive les
autopsies pratiquées par un
neuropathologiste d'ottawa sur les corps
des huit patients décédés conclu à une
cause connue cancer alzheimer démence et
cetera seule mesure tourisme ont soufflé
un peu le neurologue qui la traite à
l'origine du signalement de presque tous
les cas est stupéfait celui
que j'ai inventé rien ne permet non plus
devenir une cause environnementale ou
alimentaires tel qu'avancé comme
hypothèse de base 6 est ce que leurs
conclusions feuillatte eu quelqu'un qui
peut me dire que ce que c'est que j'ai
parce que ce qui se passe il va avoir
des communications faites aux malades et
aux médecins responsables présentement
je ne suis pas neurologue je ne peux pas
donner de réponse d'hypothèses aux
audacieux
terry lynn et d'autres malades déplore
le cafouillage dans l'anc est je file
tout de suite c'est comme des enfants
qui essayent de blanc mais un loto ben
c'est lui qui a dit ça ou au bas seuil l
emballage support puis ce fils qui a
profanes qui peut vraiment répondre les
questions directement de qu'est ce que
c'est que vous fait pour les dizaines de
patients inquiets de leur sort tout
indique que le lien de confiance entre
la santé publique de la province et l'
agence canadienne est brisé et ce à leur
départ la ministre de la santé du
nouveau-brunswick interpelle son nouvel
homologue ottawa jean yves duclos afin
qu'ils s'impliquent et s'assure que
médecins et spécialistes mettent de côté
leurs querelles et collaborent et simone
montambault radio-canada moncton